Michael Irvin Jordan is here on the show
how are you buddy I'm saying look dak
look in the way he did last night was
special and crucial certainly for the
the mindset of those out there thinking
that well maybe Romo still should be the
quarterback in Dallas which I have heard
by the way over the last two weeks and
we know Zeke can run certainly when the
Hat is being put on a hat on the
offensive line and Dez doing his thing
but DeMarcus Lawrence if he can provide
that pass rush single-handedly on
occasion that's a different ball of wax
to the Cowboys what say you I'm tweeting
as he's coming around the corner because
I started that game I thought oh my god
you're giving Carson Palmer this kind of
time and then a bunch said and everybody
- you can't ball general meta we're on
experience I said this is about to be a
long day
and I was going to pen I was thinking
it's going to be Armageddon tomorrow
tomorrow on the Dallas Cowboys if they
lose this game and and in tank Lauren's
starts making his plays and getting back
there and it's to do it's a beast it was
like he took a step man and who he is as
a player and of course took a step
towards a tank know the money that's
coming - well how sustainable do you
think what we saw last night can be what
do you think did a great job talking
about you know man every time this
dude's the game is the only time they
have a moment to pass the bar I don't
think can do this throughout the year
and I have some opportunities to do this
with what they learned on office where
the Dallas Cowboys yesterday I was happy
to see them move a little bit forward
and they're putting in that read option
and starting to use that balloons
because everybody is where everybody's
typing all eight nine men in the box
and they're knifing in the defensive end
I took that's what Denver did and
everybody's going to try to pick up that
blueprint and now adding back
put that ball in his belly and pulling
it out coming around that corner it's
going to make everybody starts holding
back and watching you're reading a
little bit but you give those guys a
front better blocking angles Michael
Irvin of the NFL Network my compadre
from NFL game named morning every single
Sunday morning right here on the Rich
Eisen show ask him the poll question
Brockman go for it ask Michael over the
pole don't you
ERV who's the best team in the NFC East
Cowboys Eagles Redskins we took the
Giants off Blessed order it goes here
right there and of course the Giants
become the base by which it all stands
on because it's the bottom of the pole
Wow so you go you didn't just say
Cowboys it was actually in the order in
which Brockman read it off which was
really skiing in now now the Eagles key
is or probably a lot better also better
did everybody expected we expected it be
the Cowboys of the Giants and in the
Giants in of that you know we're taken
because they both still to being the
only team to beat them last year and now
that's not today
well but I mean if we're going on a
week-to-week situation where if I asked
this question last week obviously Dallas
wouldn't be leading the poll as it does
but Washington looked phenomenal against
the Raiders I mean they hit them in the
mouth and then walked around with a
certain swagger that we haven't seen in
some time so you don't you don't lend
credence to to what Washington is done
so far because I think they're better
than we gave him credit that day we
thought they would be right but I
believe a lot of what you saw last time
I got Oakland in the Superbowl - I think
it was more Oakland
in Oakland then Washington being a Super
Bowl team right now so you know IIIi I
do believe I do believe Oakland is a
very good team but but I call slipping
right there in Washington called gig
took advantage of it so so right I think
it's a group game coming up for
Washington to Michael Irvin my compadre
from the NFL Network and also Showtime
and it Pro Football Hall of Famer from
the Dallas Cowboys I'm going down your
entire resume because I don't know if
you saw last night somebody whiffed on
what team you belong to when asked on a
Jeopardy question did you see that they
also want one working again last night
somebody when when they when when the
answer was Marcus Allen the question was
supposed to be what who are the Chiefs
or the Raiders right yes and they said
what was the answer that was given a
said Colorado Rockies Marcus Allen yeah
I don't think they were gonna give it
back to when I was a kid right what is
football because that's how you see it
is what you do you know when I scored on
the Super Bowl expecto everybody in the
world can soda and the people in
jeopardy was him and what are you
talking about
it was so funny why through that so Irv
who's the best team in the AFC is it the
Chiefs you got somebody else that you or
you still sticking with the Raiders know
what the Chiefs are doing and you
finally giving in to read the toys to
play with and they're both so explosive
and powerful you know and hunt in Hilo
and in the ad you know Kelsey - that
makes me
and each every he's just doing their
credible job with it that defense can
hold that and and they keep doing what
they're doing on office because they're
so explosive we used to talk about Alex
not putting the ball up here for the big
plays now listen you don't have to all
the time to do the trim or the little
play and you know move it a big play
that's the formula
that's a formula that they have found
and finding hunt is the key ingredients
in that whole formula they can make you
a great meal Irv I'd be remiss if I
didn't ask you what do you think of the
display of unity that the Cowboys held
prior to the game last night where they
took a knee prior to the anthem but
stood lockstep for it what you think
about that with Jerry Jones I find it
amazing that when they held them arms
together and walked out in the middle of
the field and took me be swimming anthem
prior to the anthem people
[Music]
anthem is not even clearing right now
and you were still boring like that's
just kind of amazing to me you know it
reminds me rich that we're getting into
a place where people are just it's it
just becomes a fight I'm not with you I
don't care what you say what you do or
how you do it I'm not with you it's not
about some of the things that people are
using to perpetuate the situation by
saying oh you know you disrespect the
flag you're doing this cuz they don't
disrespect beside before and you still
brood and I just think that's amazing to
me that's just amazing
well it's almost amazing to just the the
visual of Jerry Jones on a knee if I
told you when this was first happening a
year ago that Jerry Jones would wind up
taking a knee because it was something
that Donald Trump said I mean what would
you set her I mean that that is just
truly those are the facts I mean
obviously there's there many details
behind those facts obviously but that's
the optic
last night we talked about this when
College started
and and everybody said how far do you
think this is going to go everybody food
it will continue to go but we will know
it would go to the highest office and do
the things that is going now what's
amazing to me is even when I saw
President Trump speaking about it I just
yesterday he was trying to say that you
know this is not about race it's not
about races about respecting the flag
well I understand where he's trying to
say but the reality is you can't now
determine whether it's about after Colin
Kaepernick started it and he was the one
that's hit what it was about so whatever
you're doing you're reacting as they
reacted not responding responding is a
positive way of approaching a situation
reacting is a negative way you're
reacting to where he started and he
started it about race you can't change
the narrative in the middle just because
you want to earth take care of yourself
are you are you a part of the crew going
to Green Bay this week or you have the
the road week off now I'll wave to you
through the television set and then on
top of it when I see you on Saturday I'm
always - you're right you're always to
my left at the game day morning meeting
I'll wave to you when we get to the
[Music]
that's correct you didn't say anything
that there that's incorrect you were
here that was not fake news none of what
you just said was fake news is highly
accurate but it's also the case
[Music]
mahan Irv I'll see you soon love you
buddy Michael the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country
and audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy